oh
hey guys what's up it's halo night
yeah okay
so well with wallowitz spending all of
his time with your friend christy
she's not my friend friends do not get
their friends care bears all sweaty
right anyway uh with wallowitz occupied
elsewhere we had something we wanted to
ask you
sheldon yes
penny we would very much appreciate it
if you would be the fourth member of our
halo team
i don't think i need to tell you what an
honor this is
oh that's so sweet but i'm going out
dancing with a girlfriend
you can't go out it's halo night
well for penny it's dancing night you go
dancing every wednesday
no and that's not dancing night
look why don't i play with you guys
tomorrow tonight is halo night it's like
talking to a wall
all right now sheldon you and i are
about to have a
well problem remember we role-played
this yes but you didn't portray her as
completely irrational
all right fellas i gotta go but good
luck
maybe we should have asked if we could
go dancing with her and her girlfriend
okay assuming we could dance which we
can't there are three of us
and two of them so it's the chinese
restaurant all over again
i assure you that cutting a dumpling in
thirds is child's play compared with
three men each attempting to dance with
of a woman for god's sake
shout and you are driving me crazy
anger's not with me sir but with basic
mathematics
i'm pretty sure my anger's with you
what's happening to us we're falling
apart
who are you calling the only man who can
restore any semblance of balance to our
universe
hi this is howard wallace and this is
christy vanderbilt
we can't get to the phone right now
because we're having sex
you're not gonna put that on your
message are you no i'm just kidding i'll
re-record it
sheldon you got him in your science fire
he's charging his plasma rifle
yeah shoot now i'm cloaking not roger
kill sheldon i can't see him
that's why they call it cloaking death
man
start throwing grenades i'm on out
hey guys my friends and i got tired of
dancing so we came over to have sex with
you
jump in the tank we said no tanks there
are no rules in hell
told ya there's a sniper use a rocket
launcher
and i've got a needler and i'm on out of
ammo and now you're out of
life
why'd you hit pause i thought i heard
something what no never mind sorry go
[Music]
you